welcome back everybody to the david
pakman show luke beasley here filling in
for david today while he is away i don't
waste any time so let's just jump right
in donald trump spoke over the weekend
at the faith and freedom coalition event
in nashville tennessee this is one of
his first chances actually his first
chance in speech form at least to
address the bombshells that have been
revealed in the three january 6 hearings
that have happened so far and it was
also a chance for him to do you know
what he normally does in speeches which
is go through his greatest hits of
talking points and then kind of get on
random tangents about random things so
we're going to be looking at some of the
moments from that speech today starting
with trump saying that no teacher should
be teaching students
transgender
what that means i don't know not about
transgender people not any way you could
say that properly about
transgender singular let's take a look
pushing woke gender ideology
woke gender ideology
think of it on young people is nothing
less than child abuse
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without the parents consent and i don't
think too many people are going to be
giving that consent mark
not too many
man we we got to keep those teachers
from teaching about transgender
wow of course he's playing into the
wright's favorite fear-mongering device
as of late which is the lgbtq community
doing everything they can to make their
followers distracted from anything
except being afraid of people who are
not like them
then trump moved on to speaking about
the public january 6 hearings and went
on this tangent about how great of a
nickname the unselect committee is what
he calls it it's the select committee
investigating january 6 but he calls it
the unselect committee and he was very
proud of coming up with this nickname
and i was actually watching his speech
on my own live stream which you can uh
subscribe to my channel at luke beasley
on youtube if you're watching this on
youtube or listening to the podcast
there will be a link in the description
you just click it go to my channel
subscribe or if you listen to podcasts i
also put it out in audio form so you can
search my name on any podcast listening
platform but i was watching his speech
on a live stream and he got into this
tangent about ooh the unselect committee
isn't that such a great nickname and for
some reason it just tickled me so much
so i had to include it here's that
being staged by the unselect
committee i love that name unsolved you
know they never they actually act you
know they hate it right but they act
like there's nothing wrong because they
just don't want it they're very good at
what they do
they're con people they're con artists
i say the unselected is supposed to be
the select committee on january you know
like these people are legitimate
the unselects so i call them the
unselects and they act like oh
they never mention that i think it's one
of the great they'd never mention it
someday they'll give me credit for that
term
i had a lot of good terms we had a lot
of good nicknames didn't we didn't we
have great victims
i think this is one of the best i don't
know it's not catching on because they
won't let it catch on
just
a genius of comedy and of burns man i
can't even can't even take it and then
he moved on to talking about how calm of
a speech january 6th was he said it
possibly was his calmest speech that
he's ever given wow
can you believe it listen to various
speeches including one i gave
remember the calm words i used they try
and make them sound like that was a com
that might have been the calmest speech
i think i've ever made if you want to
know
i've had a couple of senators say i
never knew you could be so nice
next he points out that for some reason
the january 6 hearings aren't focused
on the election lies that i've been
telling of course in his mind they're
not focusing on the massive fraud uh or
he called it the stuff we want to hear
they're not focusing on the stuff we
want to hear
let's go ahead and take a look at that
how crooked it was meanwhile the
committee refuses to play
any of the tape of people saying the
good things the things that we want to
hear
it's a one-way street
it's a rigged deal
can you imagine the january 6 hearing is
not spending time focusing on the lies
that caused the event
that the january 6th hearing is even
looking into
wild
finally he decides to go ahead and talk
about mike pence and in that he denies
that he called mike pence a wimp which
is one of the things that came out of
these hearings was people saying they
remembered him uh taking this really
harsh tone against mike pence and
calling him a wimp as well as other
things but apparently that didn't happen
according to trump
one guy got up and said that he
heard me calling mike pence away now
in honesty i'm the president of the
united states
you know i'm sitting i think they set up
my guest he's a wimp how many people
listen to me it's like i don't even know
who these people are
but i never called mike pence a wimp i
never called him a wimp mike pence
had a chance to be great
he had a chance to be frankly historic
but just like bill barr and the rest of
these weak people
mike and i say it sadly because i like
them
but mike did not have the courage
to act
so there we go uh nothing too surprising
from him in his response
going on with the same lies about the
2020 election pretending that pence
should have stepped in the way
of our constitutional process
and
he's just further increasing the
likelihood that
they will attempt to do this again and
maybe it'll be successful next time and
that's what really scares me all the
evidence that has come out during these
hearings hasn't made him stop for one
moment to think
maybe i should
go ahead and move on from this and
obviously i didn't think it was going to
come out and become this defender of
democracy and you know revoke all the
things he said before no but i at least
hoped it would be so embarrassing the
hard evidence that was presented in
these hearings which i think they've
done a good job of doing but i was
hoping that would at least get him to go
i'm gonna
back off of this a little bit even if
i'm not gonna ever
change what i believe or change what i
say publicly i'm just gonna stop talking
about it so much but no his only
response to all of this is to keep
telling the lies that god got us into
this mess and that is
very very frightening
one of our long time sponsors is monk
pack offering delicious sweet granola
bars and nut and seed bars with only one
gram of sugar or less two to three net
carbs perfect if you do keto and 150
calories or under so you can enjoy a
sweet satisfying crunchy snack without
the guilt their granola bars come in
flavors like peanut butter coconut cocoa
chip honey nut my favorite blueberry
almond vanilla
monk pack nut and seed bars come in
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
macadamia white chocolate caramel sea
salt and pumpkin seed cinnamon i've
always found the flavor and texture of
these bars awesome and unique you've got
to try it at least once i think you'll
be hooked and if you don't love monk
pack as much as i do they'll refund all
of your money or exchange the product
you'll also get twenty percent off your
first order when you go to monkpack.com
and enter the code pacman at checkout or
click the link in the description